vamos ahora al problema 119 en el
problema 119 nos preguntan si 2 x 3 y 2
x menos 3
es menor que x al cuadrado menor que x
al cuadrado
ok y la información que nos dan en el
inciso 1 es que 2 x 3 es igual a menos 2
2 x menos 3 y es igual a menos 2 vamos a
pensar tantito a ver aquí tenemos 2 x
menos 3
y aquí nos están dando 2 x 3 g entonces
lo que nos gustaría verificar es y menos
2 es menor que x al cuadrado y podríamos
pensar que todavía no tenemos suficiente
información porque no sabemos quién es x
pero si tenemos suficiente información
porque aquí x está elevado al cuadrado y
un número elevado al cuadrado siempre es
positivo a menos que sea un número
complejo pero en este examen del simat
no suceden estas cosas son puros números
reales entonces en este caso como x es
real o sea como esto es como es el caso
de siempre x al cuadrado si es un número
positivo como es un número positivo le
gana a menos 2 y por lo tanto la
información de este inciso es suficiente
por sí sola para responder esta pregunta
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2
en el inciso 2 lo que nos dicen es que x
es mayor que 2 x es mayor que 2 y es
mayor que 0 y que es mayor que 0
este no es tan claro a ver x mayor que 2
mayor que 0 quizás lo que debería hacer
es tomar un ejemplo a ver vamos a ver
qué pasa si tomo x igual a 2.1
y ye igual a 0.1
0.1 si hago esto aquí me queda 4.24
punto org sin 4.2 menos menos 0.3 y
necesito ver si eso es menor que 2.1 al
cuadrado a ver esto parece complicado
pero no es tan complicado 4.2 menos 0.3
es algo más chiquito que 4 sale de hecho
es que 3.9
y de este lado vamos a tener algo más
grande que 4 porque es algo más grande
que 2 elevado al cuadrado a lo mejor lo
podemos hacer pero creo que no tiene
mucho caso aquí ya se ve que esto es más
grande que 4 entonces bueno en este
ejemplo si quedo que es menor que quizá
al cuadrado a ver vamos vamos a intentar
manipular un poco para ver qué podemos
decir lo que queremos ver es si 12 es
así 2 x menos 3 es menor que x al
cuadrado y sabemos que ya es mayor que 0
entonces aquí realmente estamos restando
algo verdad esta resta de aquí está
quitando cosas porque es menos tres
veces algo positivo entonces bastaría
ver que x al cuadrado le gana a 2x
porque si le gana 2 x le gana a 2 x
menos 3 porque es todavía más chiquito y
será cierto esto de qué x al cuadrado
siempre le gana 2 x con estas
condiciones pues sí claro que sí porque
observa x es mayor que 2 y aquí está x
al cuadrado y de este lado tenemos 2 x
entonces este lado claramente va a ser
más grande por ejemplo si fuera 2.1
2.1 al cuadrado le gana a 2 por 2.1
porque esto es multiplicar 2.1 dos veces
y aquí es 2 por 2.1 o sea aquí está el
2.1 que necesitas y este 2.1 le gana
este 2 espero más o menos ser claro en
este sentido pero bueno el chiste es que
aquí estamos haciendo un producto más
grande que el del otro lado vale a lo
mejor una forma más clara de verla es
hacer es poner x al cuadrado menos 2 x
mayor que 0
factorizar una equis o sea este es
equivalente a este que es equivalente a
factorizar una x x2 mayor que 0 y este
de aquí es cierto porque x le gana 2
entonces éste es positivo éste es
positivo y el producto de los dos es
positivo vale ok entonces ahí está una
forma de verlo y luego está el término
menos 3 ya que resta cosas entonces si
la información del inciso 2 también es
suficiente por sí misma para responder
esta pregunta de acá y de hecho la
responde positivamente vamos al problema
problemas ciento veinte 120 cuando ya
llevamos muchísimos problemas dice un
reporte consiste de dos mil 600 palabras
divididas en 23 párrafos dos mil
seiscientos palabras le voy a poner
palabras divididas en 23 párrafos 23
párrafos ok y luego se le agrega un
prefacio de dos párrafos entonces a esto
le vamos a agregar un prefacio prefacio
le voy a poner así prefacio de dos
párrafos
dos párrafos y la pregunta es si el
número promedio de palabras por párrafo
para todos los 25 párrafos o sea ya
juntando todo es menor que 120 entonces
queremos ver si el promedio
de palabras por párrafo
por párrafo
es menor que 120 menor que 120 ok ok
este problema suena muy interesante a
ver vamos a ver qué nos dice el inciso 1
en el inciso 1 nos dice que cada párrafo
del prefacio tiene más de 100 palabras
párrafo
del prefacio prefacio tiene más de 100
de 100 palabras ok a ver esto qué quiere
decir quizás convenga un poco meter
meter algo de letras no creo que todavía
no haber si cada párrafo del prefacio
tiene más de 100 palabras como son dos
párrafos dos párrafos entonces en total
tenemos dos mil 800 dos mil 800 palabras
verdad las 2.600 de acá y al menos 200
acá entonces el número total de palabras
vamos a ponerlo así eso sería una buena
forma de ponerlo las palabras totales es
mayor mayor que 2800 si son estas 2600
más al menos 200 de acá entonces el
promedio sería las palabras totales
entre 25 porque tenemos 25 párrafos que
sería dos mil ochocientos entre 25 y
esto cuánto da déjame hacer la división
dos mil ochocientos entre 25
cabe una vez 25 restamos sobran 330 para
el 0 125 restamos aquí 50 y aquí sería 2
112 estoy aquí es 112 112 entonces este
el inciso 1 la información que nos da es
que el promedio y el promedio de
palabras por párrafo es al menos 112
pero eso no nos dice nada acerca de si
es menor que 120 porque podría ser 115 o
127 entonces esta información así solita
no nos dice todavía la respuesta vale
vamos al al 2 al inciso 2 aquí nos dice
que cada párrafo del prefacio sacada
para poder prefacio otra vez tiene menos
de 150 palabras menos de 150 palabras
entonces podemos hacer algo similar
las palabras totales
ahora son menores que estas 2.600 más
300 a lo mucho que colabora el prefacio
entonces es menor que 2900 dividido
entre 25 entre 25 entonces el promedio
es menor que este numerito y esto cuánto
es a ver pues estamos agregando 100 y
dividiendo entre 25 entonces en realidad
es agregar 4 verdad aquí sarita aquí
sería 116 pero hacemos la división nada
más por revisar
no sea que esté haciendo cosas raras
2900 / 25 k de una vez 25 se resta aquí
queda 40 cabe una vez 25 se resta sobran
15 150 125 en 150 cabe seis veces y
sobra
bueno 6 por 25 150 y no sobra nada va
entonces si es 116 el promedio muy bien
entonces la información del inciso 2
básicamente es que el promedio de
palabras por párrafo es menor que 116 y
eso sí nos permite responder esta
pregunta verdad si el promedio es menor
que 116 entonces el promedio pues es
menor que 120 entonces este sí nos
permite responder y por lo tanto la
respuesta sería b
muy bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí le
continuamos en el siguiente vídeo